ربما اصبح هذا الاسم الاكثر شهره خلال
الحرب الاوكرانيه وربما اشهر من بوت نفسه
فالرجل لا يقل عن الاتيان بالجديد
اخر ما ادلى به يريد الزعيم قوات فاغنر
تغيير نظام روسيا بتطبيق نظام الكوري
الشمالي نظره لها تبريراتها لدى
يجب على روسيا ان تعيش كالنموذج الكوري
الشمالي لعده سنوات وان تغلق جميع الحدود
وان تكف على ان تكون عاطفيه
وفقا لرؤيه الرجل فان ثوره ستجتاح روسيا
اذا لم تتحرك النخبه لتدارك الوضع في
البلاد
متوا الناس على الجبهات صهر وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي سفر للاستجمام كل هذه
الانقسامات يمكن ان تنتهي الى ثوره كما
حدث في عام 1917
وفقا لبريغوش هدف روسيا الى نزع السلاح
اوكرانيا جاء بنتائج عكسيه نتائج قد تزداد
لتصل البر الروسي
اذا كانت لديهم بشكل مجازيء خمسمئه دبابه
في بدايه العمليات الخاصه فلديهم الان
5000 دبابه كيف قمنا بتجريد اوكرانيا من
السلاح الان اتضح اننا على العكس من ذلك
يعرف الجحيم كيف عسكرنا اوكرانيا
عاد هذا وذاك بريغوجين لم ينسى خصومه في
روسيا رغم الهجمه القاسيه التي شنها عليهم
خلال معركه
هجمات انهااها باطراء للاوكرانيين فهؤلاء
بنظره اذكياء ومنظمون جدا وقد يصلون البر
الروسي من جزيره القرم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات